so Donald Trump has vetoed a resolution
which would have stopped American
support of this immoral and completely
ridiculous Saudi Arabian bombing
campaign in Yemen which we've been
talking about for quite some time the
Saudi Arabian war on Yemen is not only
horrifying at a sort of humanitarian
level or given the humanitarian crisis
that it's caused but it's also been
geopolitically a disaster and the whole
point of the conflict if it's not one
that you've been following and who could
fault you given how many conflicts there
are to follow on the planet the conflict
is that Saudi Arabia says they want to
prevent Iran from expanding their
control in the region and in order to do
that what Saudi Arabia has been doing is
bombing Houthi rebels rebels that is in
Yemen but they've been bombing civilian
facilities they've been preventing aid
shipments from getting to Yemeni
civilians and the House and Senate did
something that was actually very good
the House and Senate passed a resolution
to end American support of the Saudi
military action in Yemen last month the
Senate passed it
Democrats plus seven Republicans in the
house this month it was passed 247 to
175 and this is notable because this is
the first time that both the House and
Senate I believe agreed and voted for
the same War Powers Resolution based
resolution I hate to use the word
resolution both times but it's a
resolution based on the War Powers
Resolution to get the United States out
of a particular foreign military
conflict they did this in the house they
did this in the Senate and Donald Trump
has vetoed it and it's only the second
veto of his presidency now why does
Trump say he vetoed it he says it's a
constitutional issue and that this is a
challenge to the decision-making
authority of Donald Trump and of the
presidency saying quote in a statement
this resolution is unnecessary dangerous
attempt to weaken my constitutional
authorities and
during the lives of American citizens
and brave servicemembers both today and
in the future now there are a couple
reasons we know this is total BS one if
you've ever seen how Donald Trump
actually writes you know Trump didn't
actually write it but that's not a huge
deal he's the president sometimes
advisors and staffers write things for
him that's not really a surprise or a
shock but there's two sort of better
reasons to realize that this is BS
number one congressional approval of war
and budgets is something that
conservatives claim that the House and
Senate should be involved in it's
something that Donald Trump has
previously said the House and Senate
should be involved in just remember this
tweet that Donald Trump posted when it
was Barack Obama saying quote the
president must get congressional
approval before attacking Syria big
mistake if he referring of course at the
time to Barack Obama
it does not and yet here Donald Trump is
saying Congress using the War Powers
Resolution is constitutionally a problem
so it's completely laughable number two
three or two depending on how we're
counting of the reasons we know this is
BS we know that Trump's Constitution
explanation is nonsense because Trump
aids occasionally leaked the truth and
the truth is that in reality the reason
Trump is against this is that he
believes that the House and Senate are
doing this in order to punish him for
doing nothing about the killing of Saudi
journalist Jamal khashoggi this is one
of the most disgusting displays of the
trump presidency of playing politics
with people's lives and Trump has said
remember during the campaign he told us
so many times Oh Hillary is going to get
us into all sorts of Wars and he's going
to get us out he said I'm getting us out
of Syria he said it he didn't actually
do it we're still waiting for that he
said he's bringing troops home from
conflict zones he says he doesn't want
the u.s. involved militarily or
financially in these endless wars and
yet here's an opportunity to get the
United States out of involvement in a
truly despicable conflict of aggression
by Saudi Arabia in Yemen
and he vetoes it and of course it's
Saudi Arabia at issue here once again
Trump so desperate to be liked Trump
loves doing business with Saudi Arabia
we know Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner
is very close to Saudi Arabia and the
trend remains the same throughout the
trump presidency number one trump
applying different rules to himself than
he did to Barack Obama
number two Trump once again taking the
side of authoritarian leaders number
three Trump once again not doing what he
promised to do during the campaign and
even what he promised and said he would
be doing once he was president of the
United States which is stop American
involvement in endless quagmire military
conflicts and number four Trump not
being upfront about why he's doing the
things that he's doing and there's
probably more than just those four items
although those are the four that sort of
come to mind come to mind immediately
and it's very interesting if you go
online and look at articles about this
story from vetoing this decision from
the House and Senate normally any
decision that Trump makes if you look at
articles about it the comments are
filled with Trump sycophants who are
explaining how in some way this is the
right thing to do and how Trump is right
and we should be celebrating that Trump
is doing this they're completely missing
they can't defend this so there's simply
not commenting maybe instead they're
posting articles about you know a
college that didn't want ben shapiro to
speak or something like that silent on
this because it is completely and
totally indefensible immoral and more
importantly counter to what Donald Trump
said presidents should be doing when it
comes to these sorts of decisions I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15-minute
audiobook that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spooks about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com /p a que ma n